[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIA PEROMIGO: This learning
journey has dramatically
changed my professional life.
If you ask me now what I can do
now that I couldn't do before,
there is a whole universe
I can reach now that I
couldn't dream of before.
ALEX NAKAGAWA: Getting my
Google Cloud certification
has really opened my eyes to the
vast world of data engineering
and cloud computing.
I found Google Cloud to be
the most beginner-friendly out
of all the different
types of infrastructures
that were out there.
ANUP KUMAR: It felt
like you're cooking.
You know you have the right
spices for the right cuisine.
And the combination may
vary for different cuisines.
So it's an interesting
perspective, which I did not
have before the certification.
FRAJA HODGES: I'm not
in a technical role,
and I never have been.
So I chose to get
Google Cloud Certified
because I wanted a challenge.
And looking back
now, I definitely
didn't give myself
enough credit.
So this actually
spurred me on to take
several other technical exams.
ROB LEGGETT: Getting my
Google Cloud certification
enabled me to become the
first multi-cloud certified
individual in my
place of employment.
It also allowed me to work
on cloud-based solutions
across the enterprise
and become a leader,
as well as a more knowledgeable
and effective employee.
GUILLAUME BLAQUIRE: The Google
Cloud community, the Googlers,
the developers, or
petitioners, certified or not,
are understanding and helpful.
It's a pleasure to be
part of it and to help.
[MUSIC PLAYING]